تيك توك ممنوع في اجهزه الوكالات الرسميه
في الولايات المتحده فالتطبيق الذي تملكه
شركه
قد يشكل خطرا على الامن القومي الامريكي
هذه الاستنتاجات سبقه لوكاله الاستخبارات
الامريكيه ان توصلت اليها وحذرت من ان
المخابرات الصينيه يمكن ان تعترض بيانات
مستخدمي تيك توك وفق تقرير نشرته نيويورك
تايمز عام 2020 فهل يمكن للصين قانونا ان
تجمع بيانات المستخدمين شركه باي دانس
مرارا تعرضها ان مستخدمي التطبيق لاي خطر
لكن ما يعزز المخاوف الامريكيه والغربيه
وجود قانون صيني دخل حيز التنفيذ عام 2016
ويفرض القانون تحت مسمى مكافحه الارهاب
على شركات الانترنت العامله في الصين
تسليم مفاتيح التشفير وكلمات المرور
للحكومه الصينيه عند الطلب اضافه لقانون
دخل حيز التنفي عام 2017 ويتيح رقابه
لصيقه على البيانات وتخزينها في الشركات
العامله في البلاد وبناء عليه تحضر تقارير
امنيه امريكيه من انه نظريا يمكن للصين
استخدام البيانات للتجسس على المستخدمين
الافراد ومراقبه نشاطهم واستهدافهم مباشره
بحملات تضليل كما يمكن بحسب المخاوف
الامريكيه ان تستخدم بيتجين البيانات
لمهاجمه الولايات المتحده بحملات لزعزعه
استقرار الحكومه الامريكيه واذا كانت
الحال مع تيك توك تتعلق بجمع البيانات
لماذا حضر التعامل مع تقنيات هواوي قبل
نحو عام صنفت هيئه الاتصالات الفيدراليه
في الولايات المتحده شركته هواوي من ضمن
شركات معدات الاتصالات الصينيه التي تشكل
تهديدا للامن والتهديد الامني يكمن في
اعتبار السياسيين امريكيين شركته هواوي
بمثابه ذراع تجاريه للحزب الشيوعي الصيني
اضافه لاتهامات توجه للشركه لتنفيذ عمليات
سرقه ملكيه فكريه وامكانيه استخدام تقنيه
الجيل الخامس في التجسس وهي تقنيه تتيح
سرعه عاليه في نقل البيانات وهو مثل فيه
الشركات تماما